[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you, everyone,
for coming to Talks at Google.
It is my pleasure to welcome
Beau Kilmer of the RAND
Corporation.
He's the co-author of
"Marijuana Legalization--
What Everyone Needs to Know."
After the talk, we will
have a little Q&A, which
will not be recorded, so you
can ask some freer questions,
perhaps.
OK.
So, everyone, please give a big,
warm welcome to Beau Kilmer.
[APPLAUSE]
BEAU KILMER: All right.
Well, is this on?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BEAU KILMER: Great.
Well, thank you, Scott.
And I want to thank my friend
Jeremy Miles for making
this whole thing happen.
And I thank all of you
for taking some time out
of your day to come chat
about marijuana policy.
As Scott mentioned, I work
at the RAND Corporation.
Our headquarters are
just down Main Street.
We're a nonprofit, nonpartisan
research organization
that really tries to
focus on improving
policy and decision-making
through research and analysis.
I started at RAND as
a drug policy intern
about 20 years ago, and I never
really left the organization.
But it was about six years
ago, I'm leaving Amsterdam.
The guy driving the
car seems to know
everyone and everything
associated with the Dutch drug
trade.
So I'm just peppering him with
questions about trade routes
and wholesale prices.
This goes on for
about 2 and 1/2 hours.
We end up pulling in to this
kind of nondescript building,
almost seems like it's
in a neighborhood.
Walk out, get into the building.
And the guy who runs
the place comes up,
and he starts answering
all my questions,
starts showing me
some documents,
and then starts walking
me around the place.
Well, not long enough before
we get to the flowering room.
And I got to tell
you, I felt like I
was a kid in a
candy store, but not
because I was around
a bunch of cannabis.
I felt like I was a
kid in a candy store
because I was around a
bunch of cannabis data.
You see, I was in the only
place in all the Netherlands
where it was actually
legal to produce marijuana.
A lot of people think
it was legalized there,
but that's not the case.
Yes, if you're 18
or older, you can
walk into one of the coffee
shops and buy up to five grams
because they have an
official policy of not
enforcing the law against
small-scale transactions.
So you kind of think about it
being legal in the front door.
However, it's still prohibited
to grow and actually
sell marijuana to
those coffee shops.
So it's actually illegal
in the back door.
But the facility I
was in was the place
where they were producing all
of their medical cannabis.
So they would produce it there.
They would package it.
It would get tested.
And then it would actually
be shipped to pharmacies.
Very different from here in
Venice with the dispensaries.
It actually would go
to real pharmacies.
But when the guy kind
of opened up his books
and kind of showed
me the costs of what
it took to run the place,
that's when my jaw dropped.
He had calculated
that the incremental
or the marginal cost of
producing and testing
what was arguably some
of the highest quality
marijuana produced in the world
was on the order of about one
euro per gram.
Yeah.
And so that just
confirmed to me that,
wow, if we actually legalized in
the United States or elsewhere,
you're gonna see kind of a
big push down on the prices.
And I got to tell
you, this place where
I was, it wasn't necessarily--
relative to kind of what you
see here in parts of
California or Colorado
or Washington-- this
wasn't a big facility.
That flowering room I
was telling you about
was only about 600 square feet.
So it just made
me realize, again,
that if you legalize
in the United States,
you get rid of the risk.
You allow for big,
industrial grows.
You allow competition.
You're really gonna push
down those production
and the distribution costs.
Well, you may be
wondering, well, so what?
Who cares?
But it turns out that
for a lot of the outcomes
to actually get discussed in
marijuana legalization debates,
it happens that
price really matters.
Price is going to influence what
happens to the illicit market.
It's going to influence what
happens to tax revenues.
And it's also going to have
implications for consumption
and public health.
So it was kind of that
experience combined with some
of the work that I had done
trying to project what would
happen with legalization if
it happened in California--
not only in the state, but
also what it would mean
for the Mexican drug
trafficking organizations--
that really influenced
a lot of the insights
that I provided to both
editions of the book.
So around 2011
and 2012, we spent
a lot of time kind of
putting this book together.
Get it published in 2012,
and then what happens?
Legalization.
What happened in November of
2012 was really unprecedented.
There, the voters in
Washington and Colorado,
they not only voted to
get rid of the prohibition
on marijuana.
They actually voted to allow
for-profit corporations
to come in and begin
producing and selling.
Very different from how things
are set up in the Netherlands.
And then at the end
of 2013, Uruguay
became the first country
in the world to legalize.
November 2014, you had
Alaska, Oregon, District
of Columbia all legalized.
So by around 2015-2016,
we knew it was actually
time for an update.
And so we released the
new version here in 2016.
But both books kind of
follow the same format.
It's about 140, 150
frequently asked questions.
We've got questions in
there, what is marijuana?
When was it prohibited?
What are the
arguments that people
are making about why
you should legalize
personal freedom, criminal
justice issues, tax revenues?
We've got a whole
chapter focused
on summarizing the literature
on the health risks associated
with marijuana.
We've got a whole
other chapter that's
focused on what's known
about the medical benefits.
And then we also have
a whole chapter focused
on the non-medical benefits.
But I have to say, that's
a pretty thin chapter,
since there isn't a lot of
academic research focused
on the nonmedical
benefits of marijuana.
But with the book, we had
this large focus on health.
But I have to say, one of the
biggest takeaways from what
we did is that you got to be
skeptical of anyone who claims
that they know whether or not
marijuana legalization is going
to be a net positive or a net
negative for public health.
We really don't know.
In fact, even if marijuana
legalization over time--
if it leads to a large
increase in youth consumption,
a large increase in dependence,
that doesn't necessarily
mean it's going to be a net
negative from a public-health
standpoint.
Because so much is
going to depend on what
happens to the
consumption of alcohol,
how legalization
influences the consumption
of tobacco, prescription
opioids, and other drugs.
And so a lot of
how this is going
to play out with
respect to public health
or some of the other
outcomes is going
to depend on a lot of
these design considerations
or the implementation issues.
So what I wanted to do
for the next 10 minutes
or so are kind of walk
through four of these design
issues, which I'll conveniently
begin with the letter P,
that I think are really going
to shape how this all plays out.
And the first one
is profit motive.
If you are a
jurisdiction, and you're
thinking about alternatives to
prohibiting marijuana supply,
you actually have
a lot of options.
You don't have to allow
for-profit companies
to come in.
I mean, that's what
we're going to be
seeing in California,
what's happening
in Washington and Colorado.
A couple of reasons
to potentially
be concerned about this--
Pareto's Law, the 80/20
rule, is in effect.
So it's 20% of marijuana users
that account for about 80%
of the consumption.
These are your daily and
your near-daily users.
So if you allow a bunch
of for-profit companies
to come in, realize that's who
they're going to be targeting.
They're going to be trying
to create heavy users
and try to nurture those that
are already in the market.
This is what we
see with alcohol.
80/20 rule applies
there, as well.
Another potential issue with
allowing a for-profit system
is with the creation of a lobby.
And if that lobby ends
up acting anything
like the alcohol and the
tobacco lobbies-- it may not.
Who knows?
But if they act
like them, then we
would expect over time
that they would then
begin to push
against regulations,
push against taxation,
and then maybe push
against any types
of changes that
were in theory supposed to
be influencing public health.
But the bottom line is that
you've got a lot of options
here.
So this is actually
a figure that I
produced with some colleagues
for the state of Vermont.
So RAND, we don't have
an official position
on marijuana legalization
or marijuana policy.
But a couple years ago,
the governor of Vermont
kind of saw the
writing on the wall.
He knew that they were
going to be having
discussions about legalization.
So he wanted some work
done to kind of help
inform the debates they
were going to be having.
And so I told the governor,
his staff, I said,
hey, RAND's not going to come
out and say, don't legalize
or you should legalize.
But what we can do
is kind of walk you
through a lot of the different
options that are out there
and talk about some of
the potential trade-offs
and what could be some of
the unintended consequences.
And so we have a whole
chapter that's focused on,
well, how do you actually
supply marijuana?
And so this is kind of the
big figure from that chapter.
And in the piece-- and we
talk about this in the book,
as well--
we kind of talk about
the pros and cons
of these different approaches.
For example, if you
wanted to legalize
but didn't necessarily want to
allow for-profit corporations,
you could actually
go to-- you've got
at least three options here.
You could just allow
adults to grow their own.
In fact, that's what's
happening in Washington, DC.
That's what the
voters approved there.
And that's actually what's
being debated in Vermont.
You could also potentially
have cannabis buyers clubs
or cooperatives.
This is what they're
doing in Spain.
Uruguay is setting
these up, as well.
You also have them
kind of popping up
in different parts of Europe.
You can actually
do the Dutch model
and just kind of
allow the retail sales
but kind of keeping the
back door still illegal.
But there are a
couple of criticisms
with these potential models.
One-- it might be hard
to regulate the product.
And for people who
want to legalize,
that's something
that's very important.
Let's regulate it
and kind of test it.
Another criticism
of these models
is that, well, they
might not necessarily
bring in a lot of revenue.
And there are some people that
this is an important piece
of why they want to legalize.
They want to bring in
significant revenues.
I have to say, when
Uruguay legalized,
that was not part of
the calculus whatsoever.
And there it was actually
kind of a different model.
Whereas in the States, it
seems that the public is
for this and the politicians
are kind of standing back.
In Uruguay, it was
the exact opposite.
The government wanted
this, and the population
at the time, 2/3 of
them were against it.
But there the reasons
for doing this-- they
wanted it to reduce
violence associated
with the Paraguayan
traffickers coming in.
And they also
thought it made sense
from a human-rights standpoint.
But when it came to
revenues, that wasn't really
part of the discussions at all.
But if you are a jurisdiction,
and you want to legalize,
and revenues are
important for you,
you still have other
options out there
besides just allowing for-profit
industry to kind of take over.
For example, you could
have government stores.
And in fact, there's
this one place--
it's a small city north
of Bonneville, Washington.
They actually have a
city-owned marijuana shop
where they're selling.
A lot of places don't
talk about this because
of the federal prohibition.
And if you're a state and you
set something like this up,
you're essentially
ordering your employees
to violate federal law.
So in some places they're
kind of worried about this.
North of Bonneville,
not so much.
I think the store opened
up either in 2014, 2015.
There's been no crackdown.
You could also potentially
limit the market
to nonprofit
organizations, potentially
those that maybe have a focus on
child welfare or public health.
And even if you are going to
allow for-profit companies
to get involved, you could limit
it to those kind of for-benefit
corporations that have social
and environmental goals--
for example, those that focus
on the triple bottom line
of people, planet, and profits.
So you've got a lot
of options here.
And while here in
California the state's
in the process of trying
to develop regulations
with the passage of
Proposition 64 last November,
it's going to leave
a lot of discretion
up to the local
governments about whether
or not to allow
production in the area,
to allow retail stores,
or even marijuana bars.
So local jurisdictions can make
decisions about this, as well.
So they could have
shops, but they may not
necessarily-- they
don't necessarily
have to be for-profit.
So there are options there.
The next P I want to
talk about is potency.
And one of the decisions
confronting jurisdictions
is do you try to
put a limit on it?
There are dozens of cannabinoids
in the cannabis plant.
THC's the one that gets
most of the attention.
That's what's responsible
for getting you high,
but for some people, it
can increase panic attacks.
It can even possibly increase
the probability of experiencing
a psychotic symptom.
About 10 years ago-- it was the
last time we looked at this--
right around 2007, 2008,
of all the marijuana that
was consumed in
the United States,
probably between 40% to
67% of it at the time
was still coming from Mexico.
And the stuff that
was coming from Mexico
probably ranged
between 4% to 8% THC.
You walk into any of
the dispensaries now,
you're seeing products
well in excess of 20% THC.
That doesn't necessarily
mean that that's
what everyone's buying.
But we ended up
just doing some work
for the state of Washington.
We're analyzing all
the transactions
that have happened
since they legalized.
And sure enough, we're
finding that flower
dominates all sales.
But within the
flower sales, it's
sales of products
that are at least 20%
THC that accounts for
most of the transactions.
And then you also
have the concentrates
and some of the extracts
that people will dab or even
vaporize that can
be 75%, 80% THC.
Thing to keep in mind
is most of the research
that's been done on the
health consequences,
whether they be the
risks or the benefits,
a lot of the studies that kind
of get quoted in marijuana
policy debates,
they're largely focused
on people who were smoking
low-potency product in the '80s
and '90s.
We really don't have
much information
about the health consequences of
these higher-potency products.
We do know that if you vaporize
as opposed to smoking a joint,
you're not going to
have the combustion.
So you're not going to
get as many carcinogens
from the smoke.
But we really don't know--
take a high-school kid
who smokes a joint a day
versus the high-school
kid who dabs every day.
We really don't know
if one is better
than the other in terms of kind
of overall development there.
And so as I said, one of
the things jurisdictions
have to think about is
do they-- especially
if you're a risk-averse
jurisdiction-- do you initially
want to put a limit on
THC in these products?
Because especially
if you're going
to allow for-profit companies
to get involved, once that train
starts, it could
be a heck of a lot
harder-- if you decide
10 years later that you
want to put limits on it,
it could be a lot harder.
We even saw that with
the tobacco industry
and flavored products.
It took a long time to
get flavored products out
of tobacco, and we
still have menthol.
But as I said, THC's
the cannabinoid that
gets most of the attention.
But there's another
one that seems
to be getting more
attention now in the press
but also from scientists.
And that's CBD.
And so CBD's not necessarily
going to get you high.
But CBD is believed
to potentially offset
some of the negative effects
of THC in terms of anxiety
and potentially
psychotic symptoms.
And so my guess is that 10 years
from now, and maybe even sooner
than that, a lot of these
marijuana policy debates
are actually going to focus on--
what should the
THC-to-CBD ratio be?
So it won't necessarily be about
just THC, but also should we
have a floor for CBD?
But I have to say, the
evidence isn't there yet.
We can't tell you what
the optimal ratio is.
But I know that more scientists
are kind of looking into that.
But the bottom line is,
if you're a jurisdiction,
you have control over what's
sold in your jurisdictions.
The question is
whether or not you're
going to use that discretion
to potentially shape
the market, especially
given that we really
don't know how this is going
to play out from a health
perspective.
The third P I want to
talk about is price.
As I mentioned before,
with legalization,
there are a number
reasons why we
would expect that
production and distribution
costs would go down.
Most importantly, you're
getting rid of the risk.
Go outside of Cali--
go to Kansas, for example.
There you buy marijuana, you
buy cocaine, or you buy heroin,
a lot of what you're doing is
compensating the drug dealer
and everyone else
along that supply
chain for their risk of arrest
and risk of incarceration.
You get rid of that, that's
going to dramatically reduce
the cost.
You also allow increasing
returns to scale.
If you allow big
production, you've
got competition,
changes in technology.
So there are kind of
a number of reasons
why we would expect these
costs to go down over time.
Now, of course, as
I said, price is
important for thinking about
the illicit market, what's
happening with consumption,
also in terms of what
happens with tax revenues.
So it might be
that jurisdictions
will want to do something to
potentially kind of inflate
the price.
And there, jurisdictions
have a number of options.
Obviously, they could tax,
put a tax on the product.
They could impose
a minimum price.
You could also just
have less competition.
You could also impose
a number of regulations
which could add on costs.
So jurisdictions
have decisions there.
But the thing about taxation
is that really nobody knows
the best way to tax marijuana.
And the issue is if
the tax is too high,
you're still going to
have the illicit market.
So a lot of the work
that we've been doing
is trying to help
jurisdictions begin
to think through some
of the pros and cons
of these different options.
The one that gets the
most attention and you see
in most states
that have legalized
is an ad valorem tax,
just based on price--
for example, 15% of retail,
or in Washington state,
it's 37% at the retail level.
The advantage to
that is it's easy.
People know those
types of taxes.
It's easy to apply.
A couple potential
drawbacks-- one,
if you're not smart about
bundling, people can beat it.
I'll sell you this pipe for $30
and give you the weed for free.
The other potential drawback
to an ad valorem tax
is as the prices go down, so
will your revenue per sale.
So this is why as more analysts
and researchers get into this,
you're seeing more projections.
Here's what the
marijuana market's going
to look like in 2021, 2025.
Big numbers, lots of billions.
The thing you have to
keep in mind when you're
looking at those models is are
they building in the potential
for some of these price
drops and what that's
going to mean for tax revenues.
Because I think a lot of
them are not doing that.
And especially as more
states get on board,
if you had a change at the
federal level, as I said,
you could dramatically
reduce those prices.
The second option for taxation
is a weight-based tax.
And this is actually what
they're doing in Alaska--
$50 an ounce at the
wholesale level.
And once again, the
advantage to that
is that it's easy to apply.
You just do it right
there before it
goes to the retailers.
But the potential
drawback to that
is if you make the
tax based on weight,
it creates incentives
for the producers
to produce more potent marijuana
and also for people to purchase
more potent marijuana.
And to the extent
that we really don't
know much about the
health consequences there,
that's an issue for some people.
And I should say when we
talk about the concentrates
and the high-THC products,
the other big unknown
is we don't know
much about titration.
That is, say you had a 5%
joint and someone just smoked
the whole thing.
Well, if they had a joint
that was then 15% THC,
are they only smoking
a third of it?
There isn't much
research on that.
But so when we begin
thinking about these health
consequences, that's going to
be important, and especially
in terms of you
think about effects
on the lungs and the different
devices that people are using.
But another way of tax-- there
are a number of different ways.
But the other way that
they're starting to talk about
in Canada, and I
think it deserves
some serious
attention, is taxing
as a function of THC,
tax as a function
of the amount of intoxication.
And, in fact, that's what our
federal alcohol tax is based
on, the amount of alcohol.
And the idea there
would be to the extent
that we don't know much
about the health effects
of these high-potency products.
If you're not going to put a
limit on it, at least if you
apply a THC tax,
you could then try
to nudge users towards some
of the lower-potency products.
At least make it more
expensive if people really
want to get intoxicated.
And the THC tax really hasn't
gotten a lot of attention
in the States.
Most of the people that
are writing the ballots,
they want to put
something simple on there.
So it's very easy to just
put an ad valorem tax.
But the other
issue is you've got
to make sure that you feel
really good about your testing
and labeling regime.
Because if you have a great
testing and labeling regime,
it's going to be very
easy to impose a THC tax.
But if you don't have
a good testing regime--
and you run into these
issues now especially
with the federal prohibition.
For example, some
of these states,
the states themselves aren't
necessarily doing the testing.
They're working with a
third party that then is
monitoring the other testers.
And in some of the places,
you've got gaming going on.
And I've heard the director
of public health in Colorado
say that he would like
to set up a lab where
the state of Colorado
would do the testing.
But he's worried that
if you were to do that,
you'd then be ordering
your employees
to violate federal law.
So that's why it doesn't
get as much attention here.
Canada, they've had a
regulated medical system
for quite some time.
I think the way it
works is they've got
about three dozen producers.
And the only way it's
legal at the federal level
is for you to get it
from those producers.
You order online, and then
they just send it to you.
That's how it's legal
under federal law.
But of course, in BC and
some of the other places,
you've got dispensaries all
over the place, which are kind
of in this legal gray area.
But the bottom line is there
are a lot of different ways
that you could tax the product--
tax as a function of
the amount of canopy.
But the implications that
you make about taxing
could down the line have
really important implications
for health.
The final P I want to
talk about is permanency.
And as I said, nobody knows
the best way to tax marijuana.
Nobody knows the best
way to regulate it.
So if you're smart
about this, you'd
want to kind of build
in some flexibility.
So as you learn
more about what's
happening in other
jurisdictions,
as we learn more about
different cannabinoids
and the interactions
with the cannabinoids,
that you'd kind of
want to build that in.
But it's a lot easier to
build in that flexibility
at the beginning as
opposed to try to force it
after a law's been in
place for quite some time.
For example, especially
with taxation,
do you want changes in taxation
to have to go to the voters?
Or do you want it
to go to-- is it
going to have to be
some legislative group?
Or do you want to have an
independent body making
decisions about the taxation?
So these are decisions
that you would
have to make before a policy
ends up getting passed.
And I showed those
different options,
those different
middle-ground options.
I think for some jurisdictions,
the middle ground
might be a destination.
For other places, it may
just be a step along the way,
especially for
risk-averse places.
And so another option
for these jurisdictions
is to begin to build in a sunset
clause and say, you know what?
We're not happy with
the current system.
We're going to try supply
regime X for five years.
At the end of five years,
we'll make a decision
if we want to continue with
that or try something else.
Once again, that doesn't
get a lot of discussion
here in the United States.
Although, I think it
was Minnesota kind of
built something like that into
its medical marijuana regime.
But if you're a
risk-averse jurisdiction
and you don't want to
just immediately jump
to kind of the
profit-maximization model,
you've got other
choices out there.
And I know we're
here in California.
We're here in LA.
So I imagine a lot of
you might be thinking,
well, look, the legalization
discussion is over here
in California.
But I'd push you to kind of
step back from that a little bit
for a few different reasons.
First of all, the
state still hasn't
released what its
regulations are going to be.
And there are multiple
agencies involved.
So once that comes
out of Sacramento,
there's going to be a huge
debate throughout the state
about whether or not those
are the right regulations.
Second thing to keep in mind
is that this is still all
illegal under federal law.
And once again, I would
be skeptical of anyone
who claims that they know what
the federal government is going
to do about marijuana
at the state level.
Nobody really knows yet.
But the third thing,
which I alluded to before,
in California is that Prop 64
gives the local jurisdictions
a tremendous amount
of discretion here.
So I think you're going to see
a lot of debates about, well,
do we allow producers?
Do we allow deliveries?
Do we allow retail shops?
And also, the marijuana bars--
that's going to be very
different from Colorado
and Washington in that
local jurisdictions can
make allowances for
on-site consumption.
So you can be walking
down the street
and go to this bar to get your
gin and tonic or Cabernet.
And go a couple stores
down, and that's
where you can hang out
and consume edibles and--
I'm not sure how it's going
to work with indoor air laws.
I think a lot's going to depend
on the local jurisdictions
there.
But even though Prop 64 passed,
Prop M passed here in LA,
I think you're still going
to hear a lot about marijuana
policy in Southern California.
And I think the final
thing I'd like to say
is as you're kind
of participating
or kind of listening
to those discussions,
remember that
reasonable people can
disagree about what to do when
it comes to marijuana policy.
So much of this comes
down to personal values
and your preferences for risk.
There are some people
that don't want
the government telling them
what to put in their bodies.
They're going to vote one way.
There's some people that are so
fed up with drug prohibition,
they're going to vote that way.
There are other people that
are opposed to intoxication.
They're probably going
to vote this way.
For those that are unsure
about this from a public-health
standpoint, it might
depend on the details.
And so an anecdote
here-- so when
we were working on that
first edition of the book,
I was working on it with
three other coauthors.
So we worked together
to kind of come up
with those first 15 chapters
with the 140 questions.
And we were all in
agreement about here's
what the science
says, and here's
what the science doesn't say.
But then at the
end, we said, well,
what if we added a chapter 16
where we each wrote a couple
pages about our opinions
about marijuana legalization,
how we think things should
play out given the evidence?
We didn't plan it this way,
but it turns out all four of us
were all over the map.
One was very pro-legalization.
One was very anti-legalization.
There were a couple
of us that were
in the middle, wanted
reform, not necessarily
a for-profit model.
But here it was.
We all agreed on what
the science said.
But still, our personal values
and our preferences for risk
really then ended up shaping
our policy prescriptions.
So with that, I will close.
And I look forward to kind of
continuing this discussion.
[APPLAUSE]